Faker hurt his arm took a month-long
break and has now returned now normally
this kind of stuff wouldn't be
newsworthy but one this is the greatest
League of Legends player of all time
we're talking about and two a lot of
people feel like Faker isn't actually
ready to return but simply has to to
help his struggling team secure a place
at Worlds in typical Faker fashion it
all sounds like an anime movie and
here's the plot so far
all right before we get into today's
video I want to thank our sponsor
Shopify merch is a huge part of Esports
every fan wants to rep their favorite
team or player and Shopify allows
millions of businesses including some of
your favorite orgs to make their merch
as accessible to fans as possible and
make the whole process seamless and
although we're not on org we have our
own merch line too thanks in big part to
Shopify they helped us build our store
from the ground up and offer our
touchgrass hoodies with their easy to
use all-in-one Commerce platform their
starter plan allows anyone to set up a
Shopify business in minutes and be able
to share their products on social media
Shopify made it an absolute Breeze they
help businesses of all sizes and can
scale to fit their needs as they grow
they help you reach new customers so you
can focus on what matters creating for
and connecting with your community if
you're thinking of starting that
business you've always dreamed of then
Shopify should be your first stop check
out the link in the description or go to
shopify.com forward slash the score
Esports to start your free trial today
okay so let's talk about faker's arm the
whole issue started quite a while ago
nobody knew at the time but Faker would
later reveal in an interview with inven
global that T1 summer season game versus
okay Bryant on June 17th was when he
first noticed the condition and blamed
on what he felt like was a poor
performance but this wasn't known at the
time Faker continued to play like normal
as T1 picked up a respectable three wins
and one loss leaving them third in the
table but week five of the Season
brought bad news for T1 fans on July 5th
T1 announced that Faker will be taking a
temporary break from playing due to
symptoms of pain in his right arm and
hand they said he'd undergone a thorough
examination at a hospital when his
condition did not improve and that
although no major abnormalities were
shown in the results the decision was
made for him to take a break to focus on
treatment and Recovery they assured fans
that Faker would receive the best
physical therapy and ask for their
continued support and energy now this
was concerning for T1 fans in faker's
ten and a half years on the team he'd
never had to sit on the bench for an
injury like this some likely had visions
of Uzi an all-time League of Legends
great whose career was brought to a halt
in 2020 due to fatigue in his shoulder
and arm which left them in his doctor's
words in the condition of a 40 or 50
year old despite Uzi only being 23 at
the time Uzi has since returned but at
the loss of three years of recovery and
the momentum he'd spent years building
t1's decision was likely to avoid a
similar situation happening with Faker a
player who's given a decade of his life
to the team three World titles and
immeasurable exposure to their brand oh
and he's also part owner yeah talk about
a valuable asset I'm sure they prefer if
he walked around in bubble wrap and
although protecting Faker was
undoubtedly the right decision the team
definitely missed him over the next few
weeks T1 lost a whopping seven out of
their next eight matches in the league
replacement mid laner Toby did his best
to fill in but the team just looked lost
without their Talisman week after week
they crumbled to teams they should have
been beating on paper as T1 began to
slip down the league table and they
showed no real signs of improving either
even as recently as last week's series
against KT things looked really bad Hook
is going to connect there on to cars as
now carrier taking so much damage he
will be taken out Kobe as well is going
to explode and somehow it's another kill
for the Bane as well his owner is
running away PD finds the flash
incinerate look at how fast he's going
it's a double kill one aiming's on four
kills on vain at six minutes making a
triple oh goodness me it could not have
gone worse for T1 now none of this is to
say the
say the break but it's but only made
things worse and some people like kadral
felt that even if Faker did return T1
were already in a death spiral like
let's say fake horseback right you
choose any player on T1 I would always
feel like if you put their Academy
player in they'd probably still beat no
human bro and DRX and kdf pretty easily
but uh yeah apparently not so that's why
I don't think it's just like Faker going
as made than bad Zeus seem to be dying
to Telegraph ganks poby was getting
picked off way too much and carrier t1's
clutch King was nowhere to be seen now
to be clear we're not used to seeing
this T1 this is the team remember the
broken lck record just last year by
achieving an unprecedented 100 match win
rate in the spring season and as part of
that they also went on a ridiculous 24
match winning streak a record in itself
these players that have been floundering
so hard recently are the same ones who
did that and then got all the way to
world's finals last year pushing DRX to
the very end before a rushingly narrow
defeat that was over eight months ago a
lot can change behind the scenes in that
time but undoubtedly the biggest
difference between the team then and the
team recently is Faker and it's not even
to say that Faker would have won v9
these recent games and just broke his
back carrying them he offers a lot more
to the team than just raw skill don't
forget the average age of this team is
under 19 and a half years old that
includes Toby who only turns 17 earlier
this year while Faker is no old man at
27 years old he probably has more stage
experience than the rest of his team
combined people have been posting memes
about this for years now it's no secret
that Faker gives as much to his young
talented teammates as they get from him
these recent performances have come at a
particularly bad time too as the team
tried to stay in contention for world's
qualification after last week T1 sat in
fifth place in the league anything
outside of the top six means failing to
qualify for playoffs and earning a spot
at Worlds for a team that had such a
good 2022 this is pretty Unthinkable
especially for Faker who came so close
to lifting the world's trophy for the
fourth time last year now luckily for
them live sandbox and nongshim failing
to win both of their matches last week
meant that T1 has mathematically scraped
playoffs qualification but that's not
exactly a reason to pop the champagne
they still have an absolute mountain to
climb in playoffs and so on Wednesday
this week T1 announced that after a
thorough discussion with the coaching
staff and Faker he had made the decision
to return with the Demon King back in
the mid lane T1 beat kdf pretty
comfortably ending their five-game lost
streak and somewhat calming the nerves
of T1 fans everywhere in the post-game
interview T1 head coach Tom said faker's
return had changed the team atmosphere
for the better and given them higher
morale while Faker stated that although
his wrist hasn't fully recovered and he
still feels pain he's adjusting to a new
posture and mouse grip while playing but
a lot of people have expressed concerns
that Faker isn't actually ready to play
again it's just that he has to it does
seem like a month is not enough time for
an arm or wrist injury like this to
fully recover sometimes it takes months
or even years for these things to get
better sometimes they just end careers
all together but what choice does T1 and
Faker have if they get knocked out in
the first round of playoffs next week
that's their 2023 over they won't be
back until spring next year for a team
and a legend that came so close to
winning it all last year that's just
Unthinkable imagine if Faker fails to
qualify for worlds and then this injury
forces him to retire next year nobody
wants to see the goat of League of
Legends go out like that and so Faker is
playing perhaps through the pain perhaps
against the advice of friends or family
but the unkillable Demon King seems
determined to keep going whatever the
cost
honestly this just seems like an anime
movie like you know if you had to write
faker's script for this year this would
be such a good plot device imagine that
he wins worlds this year this would be
this would be such a good scene in the
whole movie oh you know he has this
wrist injury there's arm injury he can't
play he comes back to help his team they
qualify for worlds they battle through
who is writing the faker script give
this person a raise